I'm a behaviorist by training,
so I'm interested
in understanding the evolution
of behavior.
And owl monkeys
are my expertise.
They are found from the forest,
the tropical forests of Panama
in Central America, down to the
northern portion of Argentina.
In every country
except The Guianas.
The only volume on owl monkeys
was done 30 years ago,
1994 it was published.
And so I knew that at some point
I wanted to bring all of our
research
on owl monkeys in a synthesis,
in an edited volume.
And in fact,
most of the 60 authors in
the book are from countries
where the owl monkeys range.
Owl monkeys are the only
primates in the Americas
that have nocturnal habits.
The owl monkey lives in small
groups,
what we call monogamous
groups.
The male and the female
establish a pair bond.
They only reproduce
with each other.
And when the infants are born,
the father
is one of the most amazing
fathers in the living world.